pour
rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir la forêt de mare longue à
saint philippe en parcourant le sentier
botanique
rendez-vous dans le sud sauvage a mare
longue suivre le chemin de ceinture au
milieu des cannes puis engagez-vous sur
la route forestière pour grimper dans la
forêt
demarco
au kiosque vous pourrez vous garer au
départ du sentier
la forêt de mare longue qui s'étend sur
7 hectares est l'une des dernières
forêts de bois de couleurs débat intacte
de lille
ces forêts qui à moins de 500 mètres
d'altitude ont quasiment toutes été
défrichés ou transformés depuis
l'arrivée de l'homme
la forêt de mare longue c'est donc un
véritable éden pour les amateurs de
botanique et la stèle à l'entrée du
sentier rend hommage au plus illustre
d'entre eux thérésien cadet professeur
de biologie végétale disparu à la fin
des années 80
dans cette forêt jeunes de seulement 500
ans environ l'ambiance est particulière
avec des arbres au souvent à plus de 20
mètres dont les racines ont des formes
étonnantes
ce qui est spécifique un petit peu à
cette forêt c'est que on n'a pas de sol
c'est parce que c'est une coulée de lave
quand même assez récente donc il n'y a
pas eu de sol qui est temps de se former
donc les armes et se sont adaptés à
cette situation ils ont fait des racines
un petit peu aérienne c'est ce qu'on
peut voir aussi ici c'est qu'on est un
arbre qui est tombé on voit les racines
et sont les vois bien en fait les
racines elles font un petit peu ce qu'on
appelle des contreforts c'est à dire que
elle essaie de s'accrocher au seul
existant on à certains endroits où elles
vont entrer dans les fissures on a
essayé de s'accrocher un petit peu mais
la majorité des racines vont rester
quand même au niveau du sol
comme tout sentier botanique de nombreux
panneaux est à identifier les espèces d
information d'autant plus nécessaire qu
avec la hauteur des arbres il est
parfois difficile de reconnaître les
feuilles et que sous ce couvert végétal
la lumière n'est jamais très franches
les noms
parmi la cinquantaine d'espèces
présentes on retrouve donc les bois
typique de ces forêts comme les grands
et petits nattes ou encore les takamaka
et d'autres parfois moins connus comme
ceux mafate en bois parce que c'est un
an la main c'est une yann on peut la
voir ici juste en haut c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mafate en bois c'est c'est un
poison il était utilisé à l'époque par
les marrons pour tuer les chiens des
chasseurs on a l'impression que ce n'est
pas une liane au départ quand elle
pousse son n'a plus l'impression d'un
petit arbuste mais quand elle va grandir
il va se transformer en liane et elle va
s'entourer aux arbres pour pouvoir
monter aller chercher la lumière on
plusieurs boucles différentes peuvent
être réalisées sur ce sentier botanique
jamais trop difficile ni trop longue
quel que soit l'itinéraire choisi la
redescente s'effectue comme la montée en
douceur
alors que la fin du sentier est proche
un dernier petit crochet permet
d'admirer ce pot spécimens de bois blanc
un arbre aujourd'hui quasiment disparu
car il a longtemps été utilisé comme
bois d'oeuvre pour la construction de
maisons et de bateaux alors là on est on
est vraiment à côté de lui pratiquement
enfin dernier individu de la zone de
bois blancs alors c'est une espèce qui
est devenu très très en ce type de
milieu aujourd'hui concrètement on fait
un travail avec avec les partenaires
c'est bien m pour pouvoir essayer de
replacer cet ardent dans les forêts
réunionnaises la problématique c'est
qu'il est impacté par un insecte donc
les jeunes plants ne peut plus pousser
naturellement dans les milieux donc on
est obligé de les faire pousser en
pépinière pour pouvoir les réintroduire
après dans les milieux
la randonnée s'achèvent rapidement avec
le retour sur la route forestière mais
rien ne vous empêche de prendre tout
votre temps dans la forêt
ce que j'aime sur cette randonnée alors
déjà d'une part c'est que c'est un
sentier très facile c'est accessible à
tous types de publics autant les enfants
que que les personnes âgées on peut le
faire à n'importe quel moment de la
journée en fin de matinée après après un
petit resto en fin d'après midi c'est
vraiment magnifique ça vaut le détour
c'est accessible en voiture donc ça vaut
vraiment le détour c'est vrai comment on
pense quand on pense à forêts tropicales
on a tendance à penser à une forêt
difficile d'accès mais dans ce type de
forêt comme arles on peut très
facilement marché en sous bois c'est
quand même assez ouvert assez accessible
n'hésitez pas à emmener vos enfants
c'est vraiment quelque chose à voir
c'est une forêt magnifique on voit
vraiment ce que ce que pouvait être le
lieu de la réunion avant l'arrivée de
l'homme tout autour de deux lits de quoi
il
non